Who do you say that Jesus is?
Who do you say Jesus is?
I'm sure if we went over to the mall
or went into the classrooms of Edmond
and we asked that question, we would get all kinds
of different answers.
We'd get questions or answers like, he's a a good man,
he was a prophet, or he was a good teacher,
or he was a visionary like MLK to, uh, bring reconciliation.
That's, that's what he was.
Well, Jesus also asked his followers
what other people said about him in Matthew 16,
and they responded with a few things.
They said, well, some say you're John the Baptist.
Some say you're Elijah.
Some say you're Jeremiah,
or some say you're one of the prophets.
In other words, they said, there's a variety of opinions
and views on you Jesus.
Some would be more Messiah focused
and some would be less, more worldly focused.
But then Jesus flipped it on his disciples
and he said this in verse 15.
He said, okay, but who do you say that I am?
Alright, what do, what do people say about me?
Okay, this what, but, but, but who do you say I am?
He wanted to know their perspective,
where their hearts actually were.
Listen, he's gonna do the same thing for us today.
Each one of us here today, he's going to show us
and ask us that question on this Palm Sunday.
As we study Jesus entering Jerusalem
before his crucifixion, he's going to ask us
that same question.
Who do you say that I am?
And our answer to that question makes
all the difference in the world.
And so we're gonna be in John chapter 12 to see this.
And so take your copy of God's word and turn there with me.
If you don't have one, you can use your device
or there's a Bible around you underneath the seats,
the gospel according to John chapter 12.
If you're unfamiliar with the Bible,
that chapter number is the big number when you get into
John, John 12.
And then we're gonna start in verse 12,
which is the little 12 underneath that one, John 1212.
By the way, if you're new to our church,
my name's John, one of the pastors here.
Uh, it's an honor to get to preach most of the times,
thankful you choose to gather with us today.
I know it's a big deal, so we'd love to meet you.
Come say hi to us either at the front after we're done
or in the lobby out there.
Uh, we'd love to meet you, but let me read our passage today
and then I'm gonna pray again.
John. 12, 12, down through 19,
the next day, the large crowd that had come
to the feast heard that Jesus was coming to Jerusalem.
So they took branches of palm trees
and went out to meet him, crying out Hosanna.
Blessed is he who comes in the name of the Lord,
even the King of Israel.
And Jesus found a young donkey
and sat on it just as it is written, fear,
not daughter of Zion.
Behold, your king is coming, sitting on a donkey's.
Colt, his disciples did not understand
these things at first.
But when Jesus was glorified, then they remembered
that these things had been written about him
and had been done to him.
The crowd that had been with him when he called Lazarus out
of the tomb and raised him from the dead,
continued to bear witness.
And the reason why the crowd went to meet him was
that they'd heard he had done this sign.
So the Pharisees said to one another, you see
that you're gaining nothing.
Look, the world has gone after him.
Lord, we pray as we look at this often familiar
scene in the life of Jesus, we pray
that you'd give us different eyes to see it,
that our hearts would be opened.
Our minds would be enlightened to understand
what you, holy Spirit, have to teach us
through your word today.
Make it clear. Challenge us, encourage us,
spur us on to love
and good deeds that we would be doers of the word,
not hearers only make us good soil in our hearts for that
to bear good fruit through in Jesus' name.
Amen. So instead of calling this passage,
what is typically called the triumphal entry,
I'm referring it to today as the misunderstood entry
and asking the question, who do we see Jesus to be here?
And remember John, he recorded everything in his gospel.
John 2031 says that, that you may believe
that Jesus is the Christ, the Messiah, the Savior,
the promised one of old.
And so he recorded this section for that purpose.
And here he recorded this same event,
but he gave us some different perspectives on it.
You see that in fact,
there's four different perspectives we're gonna get
to see on the same event that John records.
And so first we're gonna look at how the crowds saw Jesus.
You see it here. How did the crowds see Jesus?
So there's these people, these common religious people
who were yelling and cheering
and they were, they were in Jerusalem
for this Passover festival, which was the biggest festival,
a big deal in Jerusalem, in Israel.
All the people were gathering there for this season.
But as they gathered, they'd heard about this Jesus God.
He had a reputation by now.
He had been known in certain ways.
And so they were, they were
there and they'd heard about him.
And many of them were just looking
for his next miracle 'cause, right?
He he, he says, John says that they had seen
and heard about Lazarus being raised from the dead.
They'd heard about Jesus doing that
and they were amazed that he could even do that.
In fact, just ahead of this, in verse nine says,
when the large crowd of the Jews learned
that Jesus was there, they came not only on account of him,
but also to see Lazarus whom he'd raised from the dead.
Like, I wanna see that right? This guy was dead.
Now he is alive. I wanna see who that is
and hear the story even further than that.
Some of these were probably in the crowd
back in John six when Jesus fed the 5,000
with a Hebrew happy meal.
And he took it and he broke it and he fed that many people.
And so they're like, this is amazing
how he could even do that.
But now here they wanted more.
You see it in that scene in John six,
you see it throughout his life, they were looking
for another sign looking for more.
They were looking for the sensational.
They wanted to be drawn into something
extraordinary, something amazing.
The problem is, when you take that to its extent,
we cannot base our faith merely on its production value,
on the exceptional, the sensational.
We know God does miracles. He still does.
And and we know God cares for the least of these.
And he provides, yes, he does that,
but it, when it becomes about the show instead
of about Christ, we've missed it.
Our faith cannot be based merely on the sensational.
It cannot be based merely on
what I feel like the experiential part of what we long for.
Because then if God chooses not to do a miracle,
or if we don't get that feeling,
then our foundation is pretty shaken.
That's why it's not based on feelings, it's based on faith.
But there were others in the crowd, not just looking
for a sensational miracle.
There were others who were looking for a conquering king.
They were looking for something military
or something political, the government
to be taken over again from what it was.
That's the language they actually used here.
Maybe you've been in church before
and you see the kids coming
and throwing palm branches on the aisle
and that kind of thing and
and they're shouting a a phrase, a word,
hosanna, right?
You see it here, hosanna, that
That word in the original language means save us, I pray.
Save us. Now, in fact,
this is an almost identical quote from Psalm 118,
that these people who are wanting a new king
to save us from the Roman oppression,
they're quoting Psalm one 18
and they're saying it nearly exactly.
Listen to this, save us, we pray, oh Lord, Hosanna.
Oh Lord, we pray, give us success.
Blessed is he who comes in the name of the Lord.
We bless you from the house of the Lord.
Does that not sound exactly like
what they were saying in John 12?
Nearly word for word. They're quoting that.
And so they, they were speaking truth.
They were crying out for something.
They were looking for the Messiah to come, the one
that God had promised to save his people.
And they saw a lot of it in Jesus.
They were saying, man, this might be the one.
But they were reading things into the
Old Testament that weren't there.
See, what they were looking for is they, they, they failed
to see this as they were looking for something else.
They failed to see that the Messiah's kingdom would not
primarily be of this Earth.
It would have implications as the kingdom of God comes.
Yes, there's tangible implications, but first
and foremost, God's kingdom is a spiritual kingdom.
And so this crowd, some were looking for the sensational,
some were looking for a political deliverer
to come throw out the Romans,
but, but you remember what happened next.
Now, we don't know if it's the same people,
but a few days later from this scene,
another crowd, instead of cheering for Jesus,
they call out, crucify him.
They didn't get what they were wanting
or they didn't like what he was offering.
And so they turned on him.
Listen, that is instructive for all of us,
that when people don't get what their flesh craves,
they turn on you real fast.
So these people, these crowds, they were,
they were at least some of them in the crowd coming to Jesus
with their own agenda, their own desires.
They were wanting something from him
that he was not going to give them.
May some of us be doing the same thing today.
Maybe it's for money.
And you've heard that if you do the right things,
he'll bless you financially.
Or maybe it's wanting a miracle.
You're trying to do this bartering thing with God.
Or maybe you just say, man,
this is gonna gimme a better life,
or this is gonna increase my reputation
and I'm coming to Jesus 'cause this is what I need
for my career or whatever else it may be for you.
We must come to Jesus on his terms, not on our terms.
It'll come up again later. But that's the crowds.
That's how the crowds saw Jesus.
But second, look at how the disciples saw Jesus.
Here's the second perspective.
The disciples, how did they see Jesus?
We see it in verse 16.
His disciples did not understand these things at first.
But when Jesus was glorified,
meaning when Jesus was raised from the dead
and he ascended back to heaven, then they remembered
that these things had been written about him
and had been done to him.
Now, let's remember the context here.
These disciples that John's talking about had been with,
lived with Jesus for nearly three years and they'd seen him
and heard him do so much of this exact thing.
Yet they often didn't get it.
He said, I'm going to be crucified
and I'm going to resurrect.
And they're still like, what?
Like Peter, when he was asked in Matthew 16,
Jesus said, who do you say that I am?
Right? Peter responded perfectly.
He got it right a hundred percent.
He said, you are the Christ, the Son of the living God.
But then just a few verses later, Peter rebukes Jesus,
when Jesus talks about dying on the cross
and Jesus turns to him
and calls him Satan, which by the way, you don't want
that written about you in the Bible.
Also side note, that's a great reason
for the Bible's authenticity.
'cause don't you think Peter
would've wanted that one edited out?
Like Peter would've been over here?
Like, excuse me, guys, erase that real quick.
Satan, right? That's a terrible nickname to have.
But that's what he did.
And so the disciples often didn't get it.
But isn't that strangely some kind of encouragement
to us today?
Like we can often paint the picture that to be a Christian
or to be in church, then you have to know it all.
You can never doubt anything.
You have to have it all together, right?
This passage,
Peter's story flies in the face of that, doesn't it?
Like there's another scene in Mark nine when the man comes
to Jesus and asks Jesus to heal his child.
And Jesus says, well, all things
are possible for those who believe.
And the man says it this way.
He says, I believe Jesus help my unbelief.
Like Jesus, I I know you can,
but boy, there's times I really doubt that.
And I don't know. It sure seems like it's
impossible, but I know you can.
Ah, don't we feel like that?
So when we doubt, when we don't know it all,
when we question, we can run to Jesus in it.
Because he's not casting Peter out.
He won't cast us away either, but, but see it again.
The disciples, his closest disciples, even those
who started the church, didn't get it.
Still needed help. So what help did Jesus give him?
Well, it says, when he was glorified.
So after his resurrection
and his ascension, he gave the Holy Spirit to them,
gave God's spirit, the third person of the Trinity.
He gave them his spirit, which by the way,
he predicted would happen just a few chapters later,
John 1426.
He says, but the helper, the Holy Spirit,
whom the Father will send in my name,
he will teach you all things
and bring to your remembrance all that I've said to you.
He says, I know you don't get it yet,
but I'm gonna send you a helper.
I'm not gonna leave you alone.
I have to leave, but I'm gonna send my Holy Spirit
to correctly bring to mind all the things
that I'd taught you, all the things I've shown you.
He says, I want you to get it.
Here's how I'm going to help you get it.
They still had natural minds,
even at this point in the story, John 12,
Jesus entering Jerusalem, they still had natural minds.
They often couldn't understand spiritual things,
which is why Jesus told Nicodemus in John three,
he said, you must be born again.
He says, you must have a new mind.
Your natural mind isn't gonna get it very often,
but your spiritual mind that you get reborn with,
that's when you'll finally get the understanding.
And so for these disciples, it wasn't until after the death
and resurrection, after receiving the Holy Spirits,
they look back at stuff like this
and they're like, how did we miss that?
We fully and finally understand, Jesus is the king now. Yes.
But before all that, they were still pretty unclear.
And so, so that's an encouragement and a challenge for us.
We're still gonna misunderstand in our own fleshly minds
if we try to lean on our own understanding, we are going
to never grasp the deeper things of God.
But when we abide in Jesus, when we have
received the Holy Spirit by faith in Christ,
that's when things start to to make sense.
You start to see, now we're not gonna understand everything
because God is God and we're not.
But there's a whole lot more we will get
to understand spiritually
because of what he plants inside of us.
That's how we know. But in this scene in John 12, that's
how the disciples saw Jesus kind of confused,
but there's a third group in John 12.
This is how the Pharisees saw Jesus.
How did the Pharisees see Jesus in this same scene?
This is verse 19.
So the Pharisees, remember the Pharisees are the religious
leaders, Jewish leaders.
They said to one another, you see
that you are gaining nothing.
Look the world, the whole world is
what the Greek says has gone after him.
Like, so can't you just picture these guys huddled in the
dark alley, kind of like just muttering,
shaking their heads, maybe playing rock, paper, scissors.
I don't know what they're doing in that picture, but,
but you could be like, can you believe this guy?
Can you believe him? What are we gonna do about this guy?
What else can we do? We've tried everything.
We've tried to arrest him. We tried to question him.
We can't do anything. The whole world is going out to him.
Now they're exaggerating, of course,
but in a way they're kind of right.
The whole world is going to Jesus.
At the time, the Pharisees whole religious system was built
on keeping people under their thumb by the law
and by fences around that law,
and then systems to sustain the whole thing.
That's how they kept this kind of under their control.
But when Jesus shows up
because of him, he's, he's gaining credibility
and they're starting to lose credibility.
People are starting to question the whole thing.
Wait, that doesn't make any sense.
How come, and Jesus is talking about this new law
and different law and not under the law,
and like this is, this doesn't match.
And so they're starting to lose. He's gaining witnesses.
People are testifying about him. He's doing miracles.
They're starting to lose out. And so they started trying
to discredit Jesus.
But I want you to see something here
of the three groups mentioned the crowds, the disciples,
Pharisees, it was the Pharisees
who actually had a pretty clear understanding of
who Jesus was, right?
Like they saw it, they understood it in one way.
'cause they realized they were gaining nothing by trying
to stop this movement.
You see, you are gaining nothing
that's like they're debating.
Well, we tried this, we tried this.
And we, somebody says, well, we're we gained nothing
by trying any of this stuff.
Which reminds me of a similar idea that showed up later
as the early church grew.
In Acts chapter five,
the church is exploding in numbers.
The Pharisees are still like, can we stop this thing?
Acts five, one of the Pharisees named Gamal,
he stands up and says this about
what they were seeing in Jerusalem.
He said, men of Israel take care of
what you are about to do with these men.
For before these days, Feist wrote up, rose up claiming
to be somebody and a number of men, about 400 joined him.
He was killed. And all who followed him were dispersed
and came to nothing after him.
Judas, the Galilean rose up in the days of the census
and drew away some of the people after him.
He too perished and all who followed him were scattered.
So in the present case, I tell you,
keep away from these men.
Let them alone for if this plan
or this undertaking is of man,
it will fail like those others.
But if it is of God, you will not be able to overthrow them.
You might even be found opposing God.
In other words, if this is a man centered movement,
it's gonna fall apart when this guy dies.
But if it is of God, you can't stop it.
And we sit here 2000 years later, right?
This is a God centered movement. Gamal was absolutely right.
Plus when you think about it, their
animosity toward Jesus was so silly.
It's so denying reality. They were denying undeniable facts.
Like Lazarus was dead for three days and now he's alive.
Everybody knew he was dead. He smelled like he was dead.
And yet he walks out and he's alive.
They can't deny that they can't push that one under the rug.
Yet they would rather destroy the evidence
than change their minds.
That's what actually is said right before our passage.
I read verse nine, but look again at now, verse 10
and 11, right before our passage.
So the chief priest made plans to put Lazarus to death
as well, because on account of him, many
of the Jews were going away and believing in Jesus.
Like they were agreeing this guy was dead. Now he's alive.
We better kill him again.
It is so silly.
But I wonder, is it possible in our lives today as well
that we see and know God can really do something and
and even we see him do something in someone else's life
and he works this transformation in someone's life
and we say, nah, that can't
happen either.
We say, God could never do that.
Or we say, nah, that could never happen in my life,
especially in my life.
Yeah, okay, that could work for them,
but no, God can't do that in me.
Or maybe you're so wrapped up in your sin that that the
outside might look pretty good.
You've learned how to behave in a kind
of Christian ish culture like we live in.
But you are denying the power of God
for salvation in your own heart,
for healing inside you.
And you're just playing a game
because you're wrapped up with the sin.
Listen, stop hiding.
God already knows you're doing all of it.
He already sees it.
So stop trying to stuff it in the closet.
Stop trying to hide from it. It it, it's safe here.
Listen, I know you might have been in churches
where it's not, but it's safe not
to hide here to say,
man, I've been addicted to this.
I've been doing this. Here's my story.
I know it doesn't look clean like everybody else's does.
Here's the reality. None of our stories are clean.
And so the idea here is
that this is a safe place to struggle.
'cause we're all in the struggle together.
We're all on our knees at the foot of the cross together.
But the Pharisees are illustrations of us.
Whenever we say, no, God can't do that,
or we choose to step outside of it
and say, no, no, I don't want that.
I'd rather have this.
Which leads us to the last perspective on Jesus
in this passage today.
How did Jesus see himself
in light of all of this?
How did Jesus see himself?
Look again at John 12 verses 14 and 15 this time.
And Jesus found a young donkey
and sat on it just as it is written.
Fear, not daughter of Zion.
Behold, your king is coming, sitting on a donkey's cult.
Now, we tend to think of donkeys as kind of silly characters
with an Eddie Murphy voice,
or maybe from a different generation, the logo
of heehaw, right?
Pretty negative. Like we hear donkey
and we think negative thoughts.
Or maybe that's kind of silly, but maybe better.
When you hear this passage, you think
of Jesus when he was doing this,
he was illustrating his humility
as he entered into Jerusalem on a donkey.
Well, that's kind of true,
but there's way more to it.
John is showing us something way deeper here.
Not only is he illustrating something,
but he's quoting an Old Testament prophecy of Zechariah
written hundreds of years earlier.
I want you to listen to what Zechariah chapter nine,
verses nine and 10 say,
rejoice greatly, daughter of Zion.
Shout aloud, daughter of Jerusalem.
Behold, your king is coming to you righteous
and having salvation is he humble
and mounted on a donkey, on a cult,
the full of a donkey.
I will cut off the chariot from E frame
and the warhorse from Jerusalem, meaning I'll bring peace.
The battle bow shall be cut off.
And he, the Savior, shall speak peace
to the nations.
His rule shall be from sea to sea, from the river
to the ends of the earth.
In other words, the entire world.
So not only is John tying his actions to this prophecy,
Jesus himself would've known that, right?
He would've known Zechariah nine.
And so what was Jesus choosing to illustrate
and just being a humble figure?
No, he's intending for the crowd to see him as the king.
He knows that's what's coming.
He knows what's going to happen, and he is not doing it.
And in some arrogant, puffed up, pompous kind of way,
he's doing it Like you remember Aladdin,
when Prince Aliya Babo comes rocking into the the palace
and he's got all these elephants doing flips
and all kinds of stuff going and craziness.
Like, look at me.
I am great demanding that you follow me
because of how great I am.
That's not Jesus. Jesus
in a humble, gentle
self-sacrificial kind of way.
By the way, even as he had legitimate authority
and he had the power as the king
of the universe, he had it all.
He could have been that.
But no, he enters in this humble, gentle sac,
self-sacrificial kind of way.
And one main difference between Jesus
and other kings was how he was going
to use his royal power.
He would leverage his divine authority
for other people's good.
He wouldn't win the world through force
or through overthrowing the governments.
He would win it through his sacrificial blood shed to pay
for the sins of sinful humans and reconcile us back to God.
That's how he would do it.
Because remember, humility is not being powerless.
Humility is not weakness or passivity.
Humiliate humility is a redirection
of resources away from yourself and toward others.
And that's what Jesus was doing.
Philippians two talks about that, that he would,
he'd set aside these things
and he, he redirected that towards others.
It's the same for us. We redirect resources away from self
toward others by giving your attention
to someone who's in need,
giving your energy to someone else's brokenness
by using the advantages you have or the freedom or wealth
or power that you have to build others up to advance others.
That's humility. See,
Jesus could have allowed the crowd
to sweep him into political power.
He could have allowed them to make him the next
revolutionary in a string of attempts to overthrow Rome.
But in the face of exaltation from the world,
Jesus chose exaltation from the Father.
And he did it through humiliation on the cross, us
proving he's a good king.
So let's go back to the original question.
Who do you say that Jesus is?
I wanna push on that for a second.
'cause some of us may have been creating Jesus in our own
image, where we take the things
that we like about Jesus,
but we don't let him get too radical
because then the culture might think we're crazy.
So we keep it kind of right here in the middle.
But really it's just making a God in our own
image afraid.
That's what what much of America has done.
And I say that because I've done that
leading to a view of Jesus
that's mostly about fulfilling my own desires
and getting what I want.
Listen, Jesus is not
a genie up there granting wishes.
He's not an ATM.
He's not just an all powerful doctor to heal every disease
and every sickness and illness.
Now, does God give good gifts? Yes, he does.
But we should not follow Jesus just for the blessings,
just for what he gives us.
He calls us to pick up our cross and die to self.
That is part of the deal of following him.
And that's what he's portraying to us here in John 12,
that this same savior who died for your forgiveness,
he also reveals himself as the Lord, as the king.
And he gives us grace. Absolutely.
We should praise him for that.
And in response to his grace, he then calls us to submit
to him as our king
that he's a good gracious king.
So I can submit to him, maybe
you've tried to avoid him for too long.
You can't avoid him. You can't do nothing with Jesus.
Or maybe,
maybe you haven't tried to avoid him.
Maybe like the church in at Ephesus in Revelation three.
Maybe you've lost your first love
and you can remember a time when you
were sold out to the Lord.
It was right after camp or in your college years or,
or maybe it was right after that big traumatic experience in
your thirties or forties and
and you, you said, yes, I'm sold out to the Lord.
I need to live from ready to live for him.
But now you've grown cold
to the white hot reality of Christ as the king.
Listen, seeing him like this should change everything.
The way we spend money, the way we spend our time,
the way we parent, the way we lead,
the way we govern, the way we parent.
Everything should change if he is the king.
Or maybe some of us are giving
agreement mentally to this as a concept,
but are not allowing it to really change our lives,
to really take root deeply into us,
to show up in bold living faith.
Listen, I I, I know my own heart.
I know everyone's heart is generally the same.
We're all looking for joy, right?
Maximum joy. However we can find it.
Where do we find it?
Well, it's only found in living in response to this grace
of God with him as our king.
Joy is only found in the way God designed life to work.
That's the way he designed it
to work more than whether people think of you more than
how much money you have, more than what position you have.
And in, in culture, more than all of that,
God's grace is better and joy is found there.
Amen. So
who do you say that Jesus is?
That question demands an answer.
An answer that when you get it correct will change your
life completely.
And may God help us.